I think today I will pick the Shrew
because the Shrew is we learned about
the shoes the shoes are the most capable
and vicious predators on the planet
there are only this big but they have to
mount four times their body weight every
day is have you been eating a lot I'm
good right now I'm afraid to be near a
little really like yeah peckish but yeah
and they're and they're very tough who's
even a shrew called an armored true it
has plates in its back where a
full-grown man can stand the top of this
little tiny animal and it will be fine
you're amazing I want to be an amazing
what a full-grown Manta to stand on you
well is that all right hey what do you
say what that uh let's see uh today I
think it would be cool to be a yak we're
a natural is club all the way down like
you said we've been traveling it's been
go go go go go dimelo and it'd be nice
to just kind of mellow out to just kind
of chill and just kind of be at one with
nature and and get rid of these clothes
and you know it just kind of be rid of
those will drop you know do a little
yoga and just kind of like you know be
be on a different wavelength in the the
hustle and bustle is good of our world
so she heard of all this except your
glasses yeah no keep the glasses of
course you know i mean got to be able to
see here that just be crazy I mean I'm
not gonna get data
you